Dragon Ball Z is an over the top anime
with crazy spectacle and talking cat
things that said it did get many of us
into the gym in the first place and it
still has an awful lot to teach us about
Fitness and mindset for example in the
freezer Arc judging someone based on
their power level is folly look if
Krillin can blind somebody using a solar
flare he can conceivably win nearly any
fight this is why I find it nuts that
fans still get really angry that Super
Saiyan blue Goku is able to overcome
merge to massive in a beam struggle yes
we're going that Nerdy with this one
character X has been established as
being stronger than character y so how
did he win it's over 9 000. you think
it's always the best fighter who wins a
fight or the fastest Sprinter who wins a
race no everything from mindset to how
you feel on the day also play a huge
role and likewise just because someone
has a bigger bench press than you
doesn't necessarily make them the
superior athlete nor does it make them
stronger even you might have better
Mobility better cardio you might just
have stronger oblique muscles compared
to them by understanding your strengths
and applying a little bit of tenacity
you can move mountains bye for now